c'était aussi la rentrée des classes
pour le ministre de l'éducation monsieur
chevènement qui était ce matin dès 8
heures l'école communale d'elancourt
dans les yvelines le ministre s'est
ensuite rendu dans un collège de
versailles
l'occasion pour lui d'entamer le
dialogue avec les enseignants et les
parents et de discuter de ses récentes
propositions avec un souci prioritaire
pour monsieur chevènement le nombre
d'échecs scolaires c'est la grande
préoccupation de cette rentrée 1984 il
faut en effet savoir que près de 25 %
des élèves qui entrent en sixième saft à
peine lire et écrire
jean pierre chevènement était toute à
l'heure l'invité d'antenne de midi il a
donné son sentiment sur cette situation
il y a trop d'enfants qui entrent au
collège sans avoir complètement
maîtriser les langages fondamentaux que
sont la langue française la grammaire
l'orthographe la lecture la rédaction et
puis naturellement le calcul et par
conséquent une de mes priorités vous le
savez c'est l'école élémentaire et c'est
aussi la formation des maîtres c'est
quelque chose d'absolument fondamentale
si nous voulons relever la qualité de
notre enseignement
alors bien évidemment on ne remettrions
ne remédiera pas à à toutes les
difficultés scolaires
par les moyens que je viens de dire et
c'est la raison pour laquelle au niveau
des collèges
je compte poursuivre plus exactement
entamé ce qu'on appelle la rénovation
des collèges qui consiste
essentiellement en tout cas dans mon
esprit appliquez une pédagogie
différenciée à les enfants qui sont dans
une situation d'échec scolaire pour les
aider à rejoindre le gros du peloton
oui à l'entrée en 6ème c'est
effectivement l'un d'eux